So we really got to gender.
I think that,
uh,
there's been a tremendous change over
the last century.
It may be the biggest social change in
thousands of years of history for
thousands of years.
You had so many different revolutions,
political,
social and economic.
So many different things changed.
But this basic patriarchal structure of
most human societies,
at least the more the bigger human
societies didn't change.
And over the last hundred years you see
a really fundamental change in the
status of women.
And in the relation in gender relations
in general,
it's still very far from being a
completely ugly and society and it's
questionable whether it,
it will be possible ever to have a
complete legal in society.
But,
uh,
I wouldn't say that,
nothing has been done or accomplished in
the last few decades looking to the
future.
And it's also links to,
to the,
to the other question,
I'm not sure they'll still be genders in
50 or a hundred or a hundred and 50
years.
Uh,
with this new ability to re engineered
to create bodies and brains and minds as
the basic products of the 21st century
economy,
the most fundamental structures of the
human body and mind them themselves
might change.
So I'm not so sure that 100 years from
now people will have a clear agenda of
just one gender.
Uh,
just to give an example of what is
starting to happen.
Um,
in mutual realities,
for example,
it's very easy for a person to adopt a
different gender,
a to change genders,
to construct all kinds of alternative
genders.
And you have today like kids,
Eh boys will play the role as girls and
vice versa.
In,
as other towns in virtual world today,
it's still very primitive.
You sit in front of the computer and
it's a two dimensional reality.
But in 30 years,
50 years,
a more and more off life might be
transferred into a three dimensional
virtual reality,
which provides people with far more
excitement and far more interest than
the drab life in the outside world.
In an economy where they are no longer
needed.
And the political system which we in
which they have no power and in such a
situation,
I mean it's,
it's,
I wouldn't just take it for granted that
the gender structure familiar to us
today and for thousands of years in the
past will still be relevant in,
in 50 or 100 years.